direction l'est dans les hauts de sainte
suzanne pour un rendez vous avec la
fraîcheur les joies de l'eau vive
christian thibert nous emmène à la
découverte du canyon de bassins boeuf
c'est parti pour une aventure ludique
ouverte à tous sportifs ou non c'est un
canyon qui sur une demi-journée va
regrouper un petit peu tout ce que l'on
peut trouver dans un canyon journée donc
à savoir du rappel du du sceau de la
tyrolienne du de rappel d'idées voilà
toutes les choses la natation bien sûr
de la nappe du moins toutes ces choses
là on va en être regroupés sur une
demi-journée
mon parti
à voir
la joie
ceux-là
c'est un camion 10 couverts pour ceux
qui n'ont jamais fait parce que outre le
fait qu'il y ait quand même le côté
sportif canyoning a quand même
l'environnement qui est primordial tout
québec cette végétation luxuriante
live
à voir
où on a un fils petit rappel pendulaires
qui fait à peu près 16 mètres qui peut
impressionner par la hauteur parce que
16 mais c'est toujours impressionnant
quand on dit 16 mètres mais qui en
réalité c'était très très très très très
bien
dans la mesure où
sont adaptées dont il aurait touché
ensuite yankees traversée de bassin
ensuite on arrive sur un secteur de à
dire des premiers sauts ou les sauts
donc varie de lettres à 6 m sachant que
rien n'est obligatoire chacun pousse
sauté de là de l'endroit où il veut et
où il se sent surtout
ensuite petite progression on arrive
tout ce qu'on appelle la grotte une
passade darche où là il ya un petit
passage à main courante qui était très
jolie avec un petit mouvement de hausse
est assez joli et là nous on installe
une rappel guide et donc c'est
simplement une tyrolienne jumelée avec
un rappel qui permet d'avoir des
sensations qui peut nouvelles en termes
de rappel
l'intérêt de ce petit canyon en demi
journée c'est qu'en fait il est il est
verticale il aquatique bon souvent et
saison bien sûr parce que les saisons on
est en période de sécheresse n'a pas
beaucoup d'eau mais c'est un petit
camion qui nous permet de faire est de
faire de l'évolution dans l'eau et de
faire de faire du vertical c'est pas
classique puisque la réunion n'est pas
connue spécialement pour le canyon de
sainte-suzanne on connaît on connaît la
réunion par par parrot cilaos par fleur
jaune par troublant à hell bourg par
évidemment le trou de fer donc c'est
vrai que c'est pas peut-être un canyon
forcément très très très connu cela dit
c'est quand même un des canyon les plus
faciles d'accès pour quelqu'un qui veut
vraiment des qui vaille vraiment
découvrir l'activité en restant sécurité
on se sent vraiment plaisir si avec sur
le l'île de la réunion dans son ensemble
un canyon aussi me dis que est aussi
varié doit pas y en avoir beaucoup
il
mon